well as we get into the thick of round
six we have another special guest on the
show sergeant Jennifer Williams is with
Alejandro Thank You Jen and I love all
of this community outreach opportunities
the club has some that we have here in
the community of st. Louis welcome
sergeant Williams see this show does a
little bit about your program so we have
the Police Athletic League in st. Louis
County a little history about the Police
Athletic League and started back in the
1900s and New York City a couple of
commanders had after-school programs
combined them became pal
in the 1940s national pal came about and
currently in the United States there's
over 400 member chapters 700 police
departments 1700 facilities and over a
million youth served so we started the
Police Athletic League in st. Louis
County in November of 2015 2015 and went
from one officer in myself to now we
have seven full-time officers and we
have over 1400 kids enrolled in our
programming 1400 1400 we don't read
oning of all 1400 kids at one time it's
usually two to three hundred active at
one time so 300 kids for seven people
still sounds like a lot it is a lot
there's a lot but it's a lot of fun also
our mission with the Police Athletic
League is pretty simple and that is that
we build bridges between the kids the
community and law enforcement absolutely
necessary for all kinds of communities
well we're right now in winter months
that's it slowed down a little bit
that's cold it does not slow down we're
inside a lot we do take advantage of
pretty days but we have camps going on
constantly we're constantly in the
schools we do a lot of sports and a lot
of activities with the kids so including
chess everything including chest that
was that was started by Officer Darren
Young in our in our unit and it's been
very successful the kids love it well
that's very good to hear I mean I guess
in the summer time you go back into
other kinds of activities we do we go
more outdoors we have summer camps that
we run throughout the county
that are keeping the kids busy we get to
do things that we don't get to do in the
winter
such as outdoor swimming such as golf
hiking we're getting ready to take the
kids camping for the first time so that
should be fun and we're guys
we're gonna go to Meramec caverns here
in Missouri so we're gonna partner
hopefully with Missouri conservation for
that oh that's really so we also do a
lot of fishing in the summer people I
think when they think of tourist things
in Missouri sometimes they don't think
about the cameras but they're absolutely
stunning we're very excited about taking
the kids to see the cameras that sounds
really fun
speaking of swimming there's a special
event I'm being told you're hosting with
the junior high with Jennings School
District we actually the swimming was I
think one of our important most
important programs because it not only
builds the relationships but it also is
life savings life-changing we're
teaching kids how to survive in the
water
so we swim a lot at the Gennie's School
District and their pool was having a lot
of problems the had a leak pretty bad
leak and had rusty diving boards bad
lighting it was it was a little run down
we were very lucky to get a grant
through Channel five on the news station
here in st. Louis and we were able to
repair the pool get rid of the diving
boards put on some fresh paint a new
lighting and we're going to be able to
swim a lot more often at the Jennings
pool now it sounds really nice I wasn't
thinking about swimming today in the
morning we do swim quite a bit with the
kids usually in the fall and the spring
indoors
that's absolutely lovely well tell us
about those chest cups breakfast coming
up this is the second annual one the
first one was extremely successful again
we're at the Jennings School District at
Gary Gore elementary school this year we
are hoping to have at least a hundred
kids and a hundred guests so the kids
will be playing chess with the police
officers again and they're gonna get a
nice hot breakfast out of it that's
awesome and if you are interested in
participating or sponsoring the event
you can see the information here on the
screen go to st. Louis chess club org or
call us or email don't be shy about it
this is an amazing community outreach
thank you so much for organizing all
these kinds of activities I know that
the kids just become more and works
with all kinds of which from Chester
swimming yes everything it's wonderful
thank you thank you so much for showing
us coming up here on the show guys do we
have any more chests well I just want to
reflect that I was there for the first
breakfast Thank You Jennifer for joining
us I was there for the first breakfast
last year and there was a policeman
let's sit down and set up all the pieces
and I sat down opposite it okay let's
play and he went oh man I was hoping for
an easy win everybody was fighting on
this poor police officer
let's see Jen I was just looking at the
game of Holmby and Costin you because
it's such